first of all
it's a pleasure to be here this is my
first
one of the PI data conferences and
really excited to be here and be able to
talk about hedgerow and ml flow so let
me just jump right in a little bit about
myself as mentioned I'm a data engineer
for quantum black a McKinsey company
I'll go into kind of what quantum black
does and the the next slide but
generally we work with organizations
across all types of sectors and
industries and how they can transform
their organization to be analytics
driven and so it involves capability
building involves you know delivering
use cases with clients and working to
deliver impact and improve their
performance so my specialization I do
work across different sectors and
industries but my focus has been in
financial services and I've used CAD row
across several engagements so far and
I've been in engagements where we're
trying to solve the same problems
without CAD row in or you know mo flow
and some of these tracking tools and and
so I've firsthand seen some of the the
pain points that can be addressed with
use of these and other similar
open-source tools fun fact
before becoming a software engineer and
I was a sanskrit instructor in south
india i'm not going to go into that here
but if everyone's curious feel free to
talk to me afterwards all right so a
little bit about quantum black.we
quantum black was basically a data
science and advanced analytics
consultancy based out of London and it
started about ten ten years ago ten and
a half years ago with Formula One racing
so the the focus was always how do we
use advanced analytics how do we use
machine learning AI etc to improve
performance and and nowhere is that
a better analogy than in high-speed
racing and so since then and four years
ago we were acquired by McKinsey and
company and have expanded to from London
to North America Singapore Tokyo etc and
the focus is still the same to work with
organisations and how we can improve
their performance with analytics and
machine learning all right so let me go
over the agenda and make sure like how
I've thought about how we can do this
tutorial and so that way you know kind
of what to expect so the the the title
of this tutorial is CAD row and m/l flow
so I thought we'd take a kind of step by
step first to kind of understand what
are the components of each like what is
CAD row what is ml flow what needs do
they serve what pain points do they
address and then we will get into the
demo in two parts so one would be just
getting started with hedgerow project
and then implementing ml flow on top of
that project and then at the end at the
end we'll just give kind of a an
overview in terms of like applications
and how this could be in kind of a
production architecture for example and
then we'll open up for questions at the
end is that okay awesome
all right so a little bit about CAD row
we'd like to say it's a bridge between
machine learning and software
engineering so essentially like what
it's it's essentially like a template
for new data engineering and data
science projects and they're a couple of
concepts that are baked into this this
tool first of all it's the the first
ever open source library by McKinsey so
it's kind of was a big step in that
direction and it it addresses I'll get
into kind of what are the pain points
that addresses but essentially it's a
way to kind of shortcut best practices
for deliver
advanced analytics data science projects
in a short amount of time so all the
stuff that you don't want to avoid but
you also the things that don't tend to
get prioritized such as like code
quality refactoring code documentation
all kinds of the the best software
engineering practices how can we kind of
create kind of a track to to basically
enforce those standards across all
projects and and that's essentially what
it aims to do so that also kind of
explains why it exists like I said it
was born out of quantum black and some
of the engagements we do with clients on
some of these very intense projects
we're trying to solve new and complex
problems in a short amount of time and
at the end of those projects you know
there's certain expectations that the
the code quality is up like the highest
standard that everything is documented
thoroughly that it's self-explanatory
and simple right so simplicity is a core
aspect another core aspect is
collaboration we believe that you know
data engineers and data scientists
shouldn't act in a silo that we
shouldn't act collaboratively and so a
shared code bases is part of what Cead
Row is as well in in all these things
kind of help people whether they're just
joining the team to kind of get up and
running to understand how to assess a
project after it's already been out of
and you know for example I just joined a
project two months ago that was going on
for three months and you're just kind of
expected to on day one to understand
what's going on and so having some of
these these tools to help visualize
what's been done and understand what's
being done it can be very helpful and
we'll we'll go into how to do that as
well
so some key terms in petrol that we will
get into the code here one is the data
catalog so it's essentially a yeah mall
API that you use to reference data sets
and data sets can be in cloud storage
they can be local any type of file
system they can be sequel queries mmm
etc and what's nice about the data
catalog is that it makes your data sets
declarative rather than imperative so
all the information related to a data
set is just highly organized and if you
wanted to run your entire pipeline on a
different set of data that is your QA
data or your sandbox data it's entirely
feasible and very easy so we'll get into
that a node is is just a Python function
that accepts inputs and optionally
provides outputs and pipeline is just a
collection of nodes and so these are
kind of like core ingredients of the
kacho API that we'll also get into so
just just an example of like the like I
call it the data abstraction right the
to be able to declaratively use datasets
instead of you know saying import pandas
pandas read CSV put the file name or you
have load arguments you know save
arguments etc you can just keep that as
a simple string and so whether you are
doing exploratory analysis you would
just use that string and you could just
change a configuration setting to say
that this this data set is one thing in
QA one thing in development one thing in
production and that's kind of what's
shown here and I also give an example of
that cool one cool thing that I really
like about keto is the visualization
aspect so we have a library the support
schedule you just pip install qej rove
is and then type cad rove is and you're
able to have
an interactive visualization of the
entire pipeline and so like I said like
tools like this can be very helpful for
explaining what you're doing to people
that may not be technical technically
minded or onboarding new people as well
and in helping to understand all right
so that that's overview of what was
Kedra now a little explanation on
experiment tracking and ml flow and why
it's important so how many people here
have how many people here have heard of
ml flow or how many people have used ml
flow before okay how many people have
heard of ml flow prior to this okay
so experiment tracking is is is really
an interesting thing so it fits along
with some of the same pain points that
are addressed by Kedra which is how do
we communicate how do we how do we
understand progress over time when it
comes to data science and data
engineering projects and as particularly
on the data science side ml flow is very
helpful for that and so some of the the
pain points so how do I actually
demonstrate the progress that I've made
in the last several sprints or in the
last sprint ml flow can be very helpful
in terms of tracking metrics over time
with runs and in logging the metrics
from Iran etc and logging different
models so that you can visualize that
and communicate what is the progress
over time collaboration so how can I
share my findings with other team
members so one of the concepts of ml
flow is to centralize all of these
metrics but also the models that you
generate so each person can have a
defined workspace or you can share
workspace and you'll be able to upload
models artifacts
you know residuals from the model etc
and of course this always happens like
I had this great model I made one change
to it and now it's not good and I wish I
could go back but I forgot what I did
right so this this this happens to all
of us is you know lost work and being
unable to kind of time travel back in
time and understand where we were and
and recover work no matter what was done
so ml flow if you look at the ml flow
documentation online so ml flow was
created by data bricks and open sourced
by data bricks and there's basically
three api's that it that it has so
tracking is is the main one that we will
be looking at and so attracting kind of
as I mentioned like a centralized
location for all of your metrics and
artifacts projects and models are more
on the deployment approach to you know
machine learning services so we're not
going to delve too deeply into those but
essentially it's it's a way to store
models and then serve them afterwards
and then ml flow the way that you
centralized is that it has a UI that you
can use which we will also demonstrate
and then you can have a tracking server
which can save artifacts to s3 it can
save the metrics to for example at
Postgres database etc there's lots of
different ways that you can set up this
tracking server we're just going to be
using the the most simple set up but in
this way if you have like a distributed
team it's easy for everyone to kind of
save their artifacts in the same
location and I think this is the final
slide before we get into the code so
with CAD wrote I think it's because some
of the api's might be somewhat similar
so kid row has for example some CLI
commands that will show so Kedra run
runs your project ml flow also has a CLI
with like a run command and and some of
the stuff we heard from the community
he's like can I use both and actually
that's kind of the origin of this this
talk was we had a lot of doubt of you
know should I use ket row if I'm using
ml flow can they actually work together
do they do they is their overlap or they
mutually exclusive and so I was part of
a team that explored okay what would
that look like in development in
production and that's kind of what we're
gonna be demonstrating today and doing
over but yeah there there are some
overlapping points in terms of for
example versioning let's see in there
are different deployment approaches and
I think there's no single answer in
terms of which deployment approach is
best but there are a lot of
complementary aspects to how cacio and
ml flow work with each other so cacio is
kind of the foundation of your data
science data engineering project ml flow
creates that centralized repository of
your metric and progress over time and
with that I think we're ready to start
coding everyone ready okay so I have
this example in github so if you need to
reference back later also be sharing
slides and we have some resources as
well but I I'm basing this presentation
assuming that everyone has kondeh
installed or some way to manage a Python
environment how many people do not have
because we have some help in the back
that can help if anyone needs to get
started so I'm just gonna go into the
example assuming that if you need help
just raise your hand right and here you
can help you up
great you guys can see that right no
okay
let's see how's that is that okay I'm
gonna be taking you through the steps to
I know some of its not going to be
totally ideal in terms of how readable
it is
okay so first thing I'm gonna do I also
have a cheat sheet here for myself to
refer to I'm going to create a new
Python environment you can call this
whatever you want I'm going to have
Python 3.6 so I'm I'm gonna use in a is
everyone able to create an environment
I'm not able to I think it's because I'm
the way that I'm connected to this it's
not allowing me to connect but I'm just
gonna activate one that I already have
so that we can continue okay the next
thing would be pip install CAD row so
it's going to show that I already have
that
and then wouldn't you have petrol
installed it just raise your hand if I
you need me to slow down because I'm
going off of an existing environment you
should be able to do edge row info and
then it should show that CAD row is
installed can you raise your hand once
you've reset point okay
okay and if anyone needs help
just just wave to one of the volunteers
in the back yep and yeah okay
and then the next step would be to
create a new control project so that is
just well let's see so how many people
are still having issues installing Kedra
a couple of people if people at that
tables could help out anyone sort of
having problems that would be really
helpful as well so if you if you've
gotten this far and someone on your
table has not be great if you can help
out okay all right so next thing is ket
0 new this is going to create a new
catcher project and so we're gonna enter
the new name of our project I'm actually
before you do this make sure your inner
directory which I am not by the way
where were you okay saving a new project
before you run kendra new so so once
you've gotten to a directory where
you're you're fine with saving a new
project catcher new and then it's going
to ask you four questions so what's the
name of your project I'm gonna call this
PI data la catcher oh well flow okay
it's going to say what is your
repository name and and generally it's
going to give you a Python package name
for when you like actually run
Kedra package and do we want an example
pipeline and for us we will put yes okay
and and this should generate a new
folder in that directory with your new
project so
how many people have gotten that far
good okay all right so I'm gonna go into
this new project and CD into it and then
I'm gonna open it up in pycharm or
whatever text whatever code editor that
you use so like I said CAD Row is just
meant as kind of a bootstrap to a new
data science data engineering project it
comes with a lot of stuff that helps you
get started super fast so I mentioned
before about the data catalog so here
you can see in the there's a folder
called Kampf income if you have
different folders each of these folders
represents a an environment for your
datasets and so the default environment
will be this folder called base this is
actually would be part of your get if
you were to commit your changes to get
the local one is not committed to get so
what you can do is you can create a
custom catalog locally to experiment
with different data sets this is not
going to get pushed to get because of
the settings and they get ignore file
now if we look in base I can explain a
little bit what's going on so you can
see there's like some commented out code
that kind of gives you examples in terms
of how you could do data sets this one
it just has one simple data set example
iris data I apologize this it's really
low Phi in terms of but I'm right now
I'll try to explain where I am as I'm
going I'm in conf
base catalog llamo and if you scroll to
the bottom you'll see the only part that
is not commented out and that's an
example of a data set so example iris
data
it's a Hamel object so the first part of
it would be the name of the data set
everything that comes after that is kind
of descriptive qualities of that data
set for that environment and so for
example in my local folder I could put a
catalog yamo in override this with a
different location run the exactly the
same code in the pipeline and be able to
different results so that's one thing
you can do and you can see it has a type
and a file path so here because we
started the project as soon as me with
saying yes to an example you'll have in
your data folder you have this IRS CSV
and so this is the you know typical IRS
data set for a classification and so
this is this would be our kind of data
set to get started now when it says type
it says CSV local data set as I
mentioned there's different we call them
data connectors for for example for s3
for Azure data like store for Google
Cloud Storage whatever you know either
there's different connectors depending
on the data set you can do spark you can
do pandas dataframes you could just have
a what we call a memory data set where
it's just passed in memory and not
written out to output at all so I'm
going to show you a couple things that I
think are pretty cool that you can use
in your projects so one is once I
activate my kondeh environment actually
let me go I'll do it here so kinda
activate kentrell mo flow okay I can do
ked row I Python this will give me an
interactive shell and so how I mentioned
before let me say kind of this here yeah
so what I mentioned before is like the
the - expects of the the abstract data
sets so if I do context IO dot list I'll
see all the data sets that I have
defined to instantiate a data set would
just be context IO dot load and the name
of that data set and this is gonna
create a panda's data frame but you can
also use this for spark as well and so
that's that's one cool thing you can do
you can also
Kedra Jupiter notebook so this is gonna
open up
Jupiter notebook and you can we have a
folder by default called notebooks you
can go in there do some exploratory data
analysis and kind of do the same thing
right so it kind of takes away like all
the the file paths and instantiating
whether it's like a spark dataframe or
pandas dataframe or whatever type of
file format your data scientists you
just know the name of the data set you
instantiate it and you can get to work
exploring it one thing I forgot to
mention so how to run the pipeline
catcher a run so you can see that this
it says it goes through four tasks says
the first task is split data then train
model then predict and then report
accuracy and you can see that the
pipeline was ran successfully
now those like I said there's a pipeline
in nodes if you go into source this is
where source in the name of your project
this is where you'll see everything at
work so the the pipeline is in pipeline
PI and those individual pipelines for
data engineering and data science are
imported from here so if I go into nodes
for data engineering I can see the split
data function nodes for data science I
can see the terrain model predict and
report accuracy and to create a pipeline
you just use the pipeline API and
basically provide a list of nodes so you
can see here this is a node it takes a
Python function I just provide a string
or list of strings for my inputs a
string or list of strings for my outputs
and there's some additional
and other types of tagging naming etc
that you can also add as additional
optional arguments yes so yeah as I
mentioned from CAD row you would import
these are the two api's pipeline and
node from CAD Road pipeline and create
pipeline you're essentially just
returning a pipeline that's you know
instantiated with a list of these nodes
and each node takes a function we looked
at the functions earlier and these
strings these are just it's it's
interesting so in our catalog we only
saw one data set that is defined it
doesn't say anything about example train
acts exactly where is a raw data that
starts the pipeline off which in this
case is true because if I go to the data
engineering pipeline and I will zoom in
as well you can see it it takes this
example iris data and it also takes a
parameters value and I can show you that
as well but after that all these other
data sets that are outputted because
they're not defined they're just going
to be passed in memory and so we could
define them in the data catalog and then
they would write them out to whatever
directory location that we decided okay
great and last last cool thing that is
it's kind of cool I can do so I'm gonna
exit here I'm gonna do pip install
petrol vis if it will let me know
because I believe I already so you would
do pip install CAD drove is right and
then once you've done that you should be
able to do CAD row is did anyone get
that working right like I said were you
able to see the visualization yeah so
it's kind of what I showed you earlier
here like I said I'm having some
internet connections issues so I'm not
able to show you but essentially you
should be able to see something like
this that you
can zoom in and out of all of the
different nodes let me just try
[Music]
okay got it working so here you can see
like you'll get this visualization you
can you know toggle the theme you can
have it with the names etc and this
essentially gives you a view of your
entire pipeline so you can see in this
pipeline it's very simple I have my
example iris data I have parameters and
I can choose to see it with or without
the parameters that's passing into this
function split data it's splitting the
data into training tests that's being
used to train the model gives me my
model I'm then doing the prediction
against the the test X set data set
getting the results and then reporting
the accuracy against the test Y so this
is like I said it's a it's a nice tool
for kind of visualizing the pipeline and
this is all the stuff that you get out
of the box with a new head roll project
we haven't even touched ml flow one
night I stopped there for any quick
questions are we going to take questions
at the end but also I'd like to go
around and help anyone out for another
minute or two
any quick technical questions yes yes
good question so in the same folder as
before under comp base there's a
parameters file and this is just a yeah
mole it ends up being a yeah mole
dictionary and so I can then reference
let me zoom in I can reference as per am
parameters which you know as a string
which gives me this entire dictionary or
I think I did it in previously let me
see the pipeline I think you did it
so params colon and then the name of the
dictionary key so that's kind of just
like a shortcut shortcut syntax who
would like help to like I said two
minutes for me to go around help out who
would like help yes one person any other
one and what else
to anyone else okay
so just two minutes and then we'll jump
into the ml flow part so example ml flow
project now I know some people have some
familiarity some have not been
introduced so ml flow can basically it
has you know api's four different
languages for Python we basically for
our project we would basically create
two files one is an ml project file the
others obviously I can't condone yamo
and when we run ml flow run it's going
to look at this Conda configuration it's
going to basically create a container
with all of those libraries that are
that are the dependencies and it will
create a run it will do that and then it
will also keep track in the specified
location where you want to keep track of
all those metrics the artifacts it will
give a unique run ID et cetera so I'm
just gonna take this scheduler project
and going to add ml flow to it
interestingly so in the root of my
project actually interesting thing you
can do so I guess the the first thing
that I would do is add to my
requirements ml flow and the version
that we are at let me just check is 1.4
- oh okay and we're gonna add some we're
gonna ask I also add scikit-learn as
well
that's it and then what you would do to
install these dependencies you can just
do keto install it will read from that
requirements that text file I was like
I'm not able to do that right now but so
that's how you would install ml flow it
can just do pip install ml flow and then
what you should be able to do if once ml
flow is installed let's say I should be
able to do ml flow UI and let's see
though assess it's in use so once you
run ml flow UI and you go to one 2700
one port 5000 you should see like an ml
flow home page we don't have anything
there yet I'm going to create my ml
project file and I'm going to create a
Conda that yeah mol file okay and in the
ml project file it's very simple I'm
just giving a name to the project so it
could be anything
and then you're just specifying where
your Conda environment is which we'll
fill out and then you provide entry
points main command and for us it's just
Kedra run so that's the the first part
I'll leave that there for 20 seconds so
I can get that down ml so capital m
capital L and then all under case
project okay just there no no file
extension at the end yeah and this is
based on ml flows documentation okay and
then in the Conda yeah Mille I'm going
to cheat here but here's where we would
specify our dependencies and so you have
a name channels is for Conda which kind
of channel which Python and then which
pip and dependencies and so for this
project we're using this version of CAD
row ml flow and then we're gonna be
using psyche learn as well so I'll give
you guys a minute to get that as well
okay great so we have these two files
and the the last thing that we're gonna
need to do is to instantiate some
environment variables so I'm gonna do
that with a config SH file and so
basically you you want three different
variables you want your ml flow Conda
home the way to get this I just do which
Conda okay so you put your Conda home
you're tracking URI what this is going
to be if you type in the command PWD you
would just add the folder ml ml runs to
the end of it
and this is kind of just gonna create a
folder here that stores all the runs and
this would be something that you would
also add for example to get ignores so
you don't keep track of so this this is
like the very simple configuration it's
going to store everything just locally
in the folder I'd mentioned before about
the tracking server where you can store
stuff in post grass or in s3 etc so
those are kind of other configurations
that you can do and then you're just
going to give your experiment and name
so in this case Iris example OS I'll
give it a minute to do that and then
once you have that all set
try ml flow run space dot and see what
happens
oh and I forgot to actually instantiate
any of these variables so it looks like
it will work if you don't instantiate
them but if you want to provide the
experiment name and the location
so let me instantiate them via source
doc config die Sh so now I should say ml
flow experiment named iris example and
ml flow run space dot says it doesn't
exist it created a new experiment it
succeeded and if I go to my UI I will
see that experiment I don't see any
metrics parameters or tags because I
haven't added them but that's how far we
are so this code right here is just an
example of you could run this on an ec2
any type of server to just set up a ml
flow tracking server and then you could
just point to that URL from anywhere
assuming that you have the configuration
rights to connect to that URL now i'm we
we created a ml flow project we were
able to get the ml flow UI working we're
able to run the project from end to end
but we don't we're not using ml flow for
anything so this last part is just
showing
how we would actually incorporate it
with the pieces of the code and this is
not specific to petrol it's really any
Python project so essentially I'm going
to go into the code base I'm going to go
to let's say the data science nodes and
I'm going to import ml flow and it's
interesting ml flow for the model API
for ml flow they basically there's
different libraries within ml flow that
you can use to save different types of
lot of models so we'll be using SK learn
to save a very simple model but they
have support for tensorflow and all
kinds of different you know model
producing libraries yeah sorry okay
so once we've imported ml flow all right
and let me give 30 seconds there
okay so I'm gonna then go down and go
where my model is trained so this is
where the model is returned I'm just
going to save that as model I'm going to
do ml flow log model SK model equals
model and artifact path equals model and
so what this will do every time I do ml
flow run its going to save this version
of the model in that run that I'll be
able to reference back in time I'm gonna
return the model okay and next in the
report accuracy I'm going to log metrics
so at the bottom and report accuracy I
see that I have accuracy instantiated
I'm just going to do ml flow log metric
accuracy is accuracy and then I have
just some you know what is the time what
is the date time what is like a
hard-coded tag for a model version etc
like there's really is just showing you
kind of an example of what you can do
obviously you can do a lot more metrics
in this now I'm gonna run this a couple
of times and then we'll go into the UI
and we'll see how you can I was a blog
model SK learn log model sorry so the SK
learn module yeah
[Music]
so that ran and if I go to the UI now in
my iris example then see the tags and
metrics etc so I'm gonna run this a
couple of times and so you can see that
I get a whole bunch of runs and what I
can do you know over time I can filter
these by tag I can filter them by you
know time stamp etc and then I can
compare them over time as well so it's
kind of one of the benefits to ml flow
and then each of these of course I can
then get the artifacts for each of them
so if I wanted to get all the artifacts
I can go in here get the model know with
the environment etc everything so really
useful this is for local development in
terms of production izing me and some
colleagues we wrote an article on how
you would productionize this with data
bricks it's actually amazingly easy
because ml flow is so nicely integrated
with data bricks so they have a runs tab
here and we have instructions in the
header documentation how to deploy a
casual pipeline on data bricks and in
what you would do is all you just
preface with with ml flow start run run
main and run main is just for reference
is this run dot pi in the CAD roll
pipeline and this will save all the runs
here on this tab over here which you can
you basically have access to the same UI
that we have it's it's just like it's
own tracking server let's see if it will
show me this so slow but essentially it
will open up the same UI as this that
you can use I'm on a very slow
connection so and that brings me let's
say fan yeah so essentially this is
this is kind of how keto and ml flow fit
together for local development you have
this collaborative code base that data
engineers data scientists are using
together you're able to you know create
pipelines visualize them segment them by
tag and you know etc an ml flow helps to
store all of the the development
tracking around that and then when you
deploy it you can deploy it on data
bricks there's lots of different ways of
deploying this is just one example and
ml flow is so integrated with data
bricks that you're able to you know
create the the package of your hedgerow
repository run it with ml flow and have
the same thing in production so so we
feel like keto ml flow no they're
they're not conflicting tools to be used
they act and they they do act very
complementary together and we've seen a
lot of people get very good results out
of this so also on the subject of
experiment tracking quantum black we
work on a lot of internal projects we
also have a tool called performance AI
we are working to get this open source
soon and so this is also in the space of
experiment tracking it's something just
to be just to keep your eyes out for and
you know there should be some news in
this space as well here for CAD row we
have very extensive documentation on
read the docs petro community catcher
community is very active on github and
so I encourage you to reach out post
issues and reach out to us and talk to
us and let us know how we can improve it
and work together and you know there's
there's hedgerow there's questions on
Stack Overflow tired catcher that you
can also look at as well there's also a
very good tutorial in the scheduler
documentation that you should check out
spaceflight said it goes over all of the
data connectors how to create custom
data connectors working with data breaks
working with PI spark
all types of advanced features that you
can look into and we have some time for
Q&A so happy to answer anyone's
questions yes in wait for them wait for
the mic please so that everyone can hear
so we do a lot of data science data
engineering pipelines with spark submit
jobs is there any support in Quito for
spark submits it's interesting the way
that I've typically is a good question
so the way that we have typically seen
it I've primarily worked on projects
where data bricks is kind of the end
environment and so data bricks has a
library called data bricks connect where
you can code locally but submit the jobs
to the cluster the spark parts of the
jobs that's what we have used but it
sounds like you might be dealing with a
different environment for how to submit
the the spark job ensure it should be
possible I just don't have specific
instructions maybe we can talk
afterwards yeah yes
what are the minimum requirements for
architecture or whatever that a company
or client must have in order to be able
to implement a CAD drone ml flow
successfully like what do you look for
yeah so I mean like Python version is a
big thing right so most you know I
specified Python 3.6 because that's like
very kind of stable at this point that's
generally what we are using so I think
Python version is a big one if a company
is on like Python 2 or like older
versions there could be issues that you
need to resolve and I think the same
thing applies with ml flow as well I
think there's like minimum Python
versions that they support that's really
the only hard requirement that I can
think of so for I'm good so for 4
resources the the slides I have the link
to the slide here but I'll also be
posting it on LinkedIn later feel free
to follow on LinkedIn or follow quantum
black you can find more about quantum
black at quantum black calm and happy to
take any questions offline as well if
anyone's interested in learning more
thank you very much
[Applause]